okay hi everyone it's a pleasure to be
here
so my titles on training intelligent
game agents with deep reinforcement
learning and so what can you expect so
if there was a subtitle this talk I
would call it yd purring first
reinforcement learning is so hard to get
working there's a fair bit of maps and
hopefully you've kind of had experience
with deep learning and kind of
understand terms like likelihood
stochastic gradient etcetera and you've
had experience working with any auto
grad library even if you're kind of very
kind of new to machine learning and you
should hopefully be able to kind of get
the intuition about kind of how we train
agents and deep reinforcement learning
yeah so there's a lot to get through and
yeah don't be kind of worried if I you
don't digest everything so just a quick
intro kind of about me so I currently
work in the research and development
team found this Factory I studied my
masters in physics and I'm very kind of
obsessed with deep reinforcement
learning and hopefully I can kind of
convey that kind of passion to you today
so they're kind of outline for this talk
is we're going to talk about we're just
going to have an introduction to what
deep reinforcement learning is Markov
decision processes MVPs are the kind of
backbone behind reinforcement learning
in general and then we've got three kind
of kind of classes of methods main
classes of methods used in reinforcement
learning policy gradients value based
methods and actor critics doll methods
and then we'll kind of conclude after
that and so kind of just to start off
like it's a good idea to you see kind of
where reinforcement learning fits in to
into machine learning so supervised
learning
is very much about kind of building a
model that map's data to labels and
you've got a very well-defined task
unsupervised learning is a kind of bit
more broader and it's usually kind of
involves kind of kind of fundamentally
understanding the kind of structure of
probability distribution of your data
and kind of lots of kind of techniques
like clustering dimensionality reduction
density estimation generating new
samples and fit into unsupervised
learning and reinforcement learning is
about maximizing the rewards we get from
the environment so it's it's not
entirely supervised learning it's not
entirely unsupervised learning it's kind
of how it fits you know in its own kind
of domain because so the main task is
that we're trying to kind of maximize
we're trying to learn a behavior or a
policy in the environment that we're in
and we don't
so in supervised learning you've really
got the data to start off with you've
really got your labels but we actually
interact in the environment and then we
get data so and how we kind of choose to
interact with environment kind of
changes what a data we've got we get and
that kind of changes how we learn and so
a good example is kind of like when
you've got a toddler you know who kind
of kind of approaches a fire or flame
for the first time and they're not going
to do it again
and because they've learnt that that
action corresponds to some negative
reward so other things which we'll kind
of see later is that the feedback can be
delayed and we usually have a goal in
mind but we don't necessarily have to
and yes so we don't have labels per se
we have the reward signals and
so here's kind of a few kind of kind of
objective a few kind of typical machine
learning tasks and kind of let's kind of
discuss about where they fall in so kind
of things like detecting tumors from MRI
scans I think you know it's pretty clear
that it's you're using supervised
learning because you need to have labels
of you know you need to have positive or
negative labels you know to learn once
what's two more isn't compression and so
there's no labels in that so it's
unsupervised something like predicting
house prices you know you'd probably
have kind of labels like you know
distance to a station and other kind of
things which will affect house price and
then you would kind of build a function
approximately at that kind of maximizes
that kind of likelihood of kind of
getting the right kind of house prices
so fake news generator that's a bit of a
kind of it's a weird one so usually for
language models we're kind of so
language models like fake news generator
is it's unsupervised because you haven't
got any true labels you're learning
you're learning the kind of probability
you you're maximizing likelihood that
your tokens your words your sentences
come from your data the way you train it
is very akin to supervised learning so
like if you've kind of seen how like a
text generators trained its trained like
using like an auto regressive models
where you you've got your kind of
probability distribution of all your
tokens and then you can of factorize it
out and the label is your next token so
you're maximizing for example like the
probability of Tok
ten given token 0 to 9 or 1 to 9 yep
yes so and a total earning to walk so
that doesn't really fit in to
unsupervised learning and because you're
kind of learning kind of kind of really
you're trying to maximize your kind of
reward in your environment but it's not
supervised learning as well because you
don't have the labels to start off with
you kind of interact with your
environment the table kind of changes
how they move it cetera to kind of learn
kind of what's how to walk and how not
to walk okay so I'll go through this
quickly so here's some examples of
reinforcement learning and so the first
one top left is the kind of is the kind
of nature article about alphago and I
think that was one of the kind of first
kind of bigfeetz in reinforcement
learning you've got a typical typically
kind of robotics you would try to use
kind of reinforcement learning for
example to to pick up an object so you
would have rewards for example where you
have negative one reward everywhere and
that you have a large positive reward
once the hand reaches the object and
you've got personalised ad
recommendations that's an example of
reinforcement learning self-driving cars
and sometimes you can train a machine
translation using reinforcement learning
C up so deep reinforcement learning is
literally kind of deep learning plus
reinforcement learning so you have you
have your kind of an environment where
so say you're trying to kind of solve a
Rubik's Cube you take an action so
that's something you can control
and your action is kind of
by your policy that's what we're trying
to learn and so given the particular
configuration we're trying to learn an
action that maximizes the total reward
we trend then and a policy that
maximizes and total reward and so you
have your Rubik's Cube you take an
action and then you end up with a
different configuration of your Rubik's
Cube so that's the next day and you also
kind of get a reward whether you're that
could be for example with you or whether
you've got for example one side all the
same color etc and your goal is to kind
of kind of have a policy or kind of a
set of actions which maximize your
expected reward and that can be kind of
defined as kind of maximizing theta so
our policy is kind of parametrized by
theta and that maximizes expected reward
and so that's the probability of
directory and I've just I can deflect
dries it out
okay so I'll talk about this kind of
briefly so MDP kind of gives us a kind
of formulation of how an agent kind of
can interact in this environment and
it's the backbone of RL so usually in an
MDP you have you're in a particular
state and you can choose an action and
you get to another state and sometimes
you choose you're in one state and you
choose an action and you get to one
particular state but then next time you
pass by that state and you choose the
same action you enter a different state
so it's governed by kind of transition
kind of probabilities and the kind of
the kind of key thing about MVPs is that
though they obeyed a Markov property
which is that the probability that you
enter the next state given your current
state is always constant it's
independent of your history and that's
something that kind of view we need in
reinforcement learning
for things to work yeah so it's
basically our sufficient statistic so
I'm a sufficient statistic is so for
example in a recurrent neural network
your latest hidden state is if you were
kind of using RNN to kind of model
identity than your latest hidden state
would be your and sufficient cystic um
so just to be a bit more formal so MDP
and has a set of possible states so for
example all the places delivery drone
can be a set of actions so it could be
the different kind of motions I'm moving
forward back left up right down or kind
of staying stationary their transition
probabilities usually they're
deterministic so if you take if you're
in a state and you take an action you'll
usually always end up in the next thing
but sometimes in different environments
you they're not deterministic and you
need to kind of consider transition
probabilities kind of carefully then you
have your rewards so the rewards are
usually man-made so in this case for
example you could give a positive reward
when the drone delivers the package to
the right house or a -10 reward for
example if it livers to if it is doing
nothing or it's delivering it to the
wrong house oh yeah and sometimes you
have states which are terminal which
means that you kind of stop and your
rollout is finished and so an example
would be if a drone crashes into a tree
or if it completes his mission okay so
okay so I'll just quickly run through
this
usually we don't want to calculate the
exact sum of the rewards because if you
have and if you have like an infinite
trajectory then your rewards will kind
of diverge if you're off all your
rewards are positive and so usually we
apply discount factor usually about
something like no point 999 and set out
the rewards kind of further away are
still relevant furthering to the beach
are still relevant but like their total
reward is still capped yeah and it also
helps us reduce the variance as well
usually we're not usually kind of we
want to talk about the expected kind of
return rather than just a return in a
single rollout so that's the Q function
and the Q function can be just written
out like an expectation under your
policy so the PI here's a denotes your
policy so if you yeah so if you have a
different policy then you're gonna have
a different Q value because your total
rewards are we kind of different or your
return will be different and that useful
no value is an Adu SFIL kind of function
is their value function and that's
similar to a key function but it's the
expected reward given a particular state
you're in
so yeah we want to find a policy that
visits optimal value states or we want
to equivalently you should convince
yourself that it's the same we want to
kind of have a policy that kind of
always chooses the states that give us
the maximum return so we label them as Q
star so Q star is the optimal action
value okay okay so who you mentioned
that just a quick side note so usually
in a real world we're working with
partially observable MVPs and their MVPs
that don't obey the Markov property a
good example would be for example if you
saw if you had a at this state if you
had a state of a picture of the car and
then you know where its location is that
for example you don't know whether it's
driving right or left or backwards or
forward you don't know it's acceleration
usually kind of for in order to turn a
harshly observable MDP into an MDP we
take into account its previous states as
well so for example if you know where
the car was like in the last and a few
seconds then you can work out its
velocity acceleration and everything you
need to know so the first kind of
reinforcement learning method we see is
policy gradient method so it's called
reinforce and so remember our objective
is to maximize is to find the policy
parameter theta that maximizes the
expected return in our environment so we
just call j the expected return usually
we kind of use jane for that kind of
objective
and so we want to in order to find a
maximum we need to take the grading of
it but it's not so straightforward
because you can't take a grading of
expectations so we use something called
a school function trick or it's also
called a log derivative trick or
reinforce trick and so if you kind of
write the expectation as integral then
you can take so grad of Pi can be
rewritten as by grad log of Pi and then
we can take the PI out and then we've
got an expectation over an objective
that we can other gradients that we can
compute and the nice thing about this is
that so
or when we write it out when we kind of
factorize out the kind of policy of a
achoo directory then we can see that the
states and transition dynamics are
independent of theta and so we can kind
of get rid of them and so we're left
with this kind of objective okay all
right so so how do we train this and so
we can write expectation as just kind of
a sum of an average and and the variance
of this is very PI so one thing one
trick we can do is is like we realize
that the future actions don't don't
depend on the past and don't determine
the past rewards so we only need to find
out the rewards to go when we're at a
particular state so this is the Q
function by the way as well so that the
thing inside a bracket can be looked at
as the Q function when it's in
expectation
okay so so we're computing the maximum
likelihood estimate of our policy so
when we're using like Auto graduals
and we this kind of objective is quite
nice because it means that we can just
get rid of the grad and just take the
loss as this surrogate loss and so it
can be seen as kind of a product of two
parts so the first part is kind of very
familiar in supervised learning and so
it's basically like a supervised
objective where your actions are kind of
the labels in your as this you're kind
of air data and so if you're working in
a discrete action space then your
maximum your negative likelihood and is
usually computed with a cross entropy or
in the case where it's continuous you
kind of make kind of assumption you make
the assumption that probably
distribution is Gaussian and then you do
the squared error between your target
and you estimate and so it's weighted by
the return so what this means is that
we're kind of taking larger steps where
you've got a kind of bigger returns okay
so in the first notebook and there is a
kind of a task on implementing the
policy gradient and so you might want to
like kind of just take a few minutes to
kind of have a look look at that
okay all right there should have been an
email sent out with github link okay
okay
but I want to kind of show it here as
well yep yep
okay one second I think I'll show it in
here instead how do I switch
all right how do you think that she's
stripe right than left by your cursor on
top
all right [ __ ] all right okay so um
I'll just show it quickly over here and
yes sure
Oh
oh wait there's somebody all right okay
oops sorry fun see from
yep all right so oh yeah so different
zip files so yes so it's lost in Bayes
and then training punching game agents
redoing possible enemy and so yeah it's
the first one in policy gradient
okay I think I'll just kind of quickly
explain what's going on here right now
so we're using the opening eyes gym
environment and so so with the
environment we can kind of do kind of
rollouts in we can do rollouts and get
the state actions and rewards as we're
going along and so over here we kind of
build a policy Network I tried to start
with TF layers of dense intensive 7.13
and for some reason it was ten times
slower to do the forward pass I'm not
sure why and so here we're computing the
policy
as a function of our stinks so the size
of that should be kind of the number of
actions which is - and over here we kind
of so our objective is here so it's kind
of the mean of the log policy actions
times that kind of rewards to go yeah
sure okay that's what about and over
here I've added so you can ignore you
don't need to worry about this part too
much but and I've added an entropy term
because it helps with kind of
exploration and making sure it doesn't
kind of deposit isn't on veg to working
okay and yeah so you kind of compute
that loss and then you kind of update
your network and then you continue to do
rollouts
and then kind of so in here to carpool
it's the aim of the game is to kind of
get it to balance and so I did that okay
so I'll just go back to the reward does
everyone have access to this the drink
okay I'm going to try to get back to the
PowerPoint now one second
all right yeah
okay
so kind of unfortunately kind of the
algorithm we're using is quite poor
because the grading of the variance of
the gradients are quite large and so
kind of what I did to kind of show is
and I kind of compared to kind of
gradient methods once called one the one
we're using is reinforced and other ones
called repair motorization trick and we
can't use a rebound terrorization trick
and because our we can't our we can't
differentiate our rewards with respect
to kind of our policy parameters but I
put its yeah
so it's a kind of a weird objective and
but you can think of it as like fixed
like a VA with a fixed decoder and
ignoring the KL divergence term so we're
trying to find we're trying to find the
encoder parameters that maximizes dis
likelihood and both P and Q are Gaussian
distributions and Beck hues mean and
standard deviation are parameterized by
a neural network so all this skip this
part and okay so so the black so you can
ignore the green dot the black dot is
the kind of destination of awkward and
crosses orders to go that's when the
cross is kind of converged to the black
dot and we've kind of maximized our
likelihood and so you can see that's it
kind of actually you can't actually see
this on the screen and but there's
supposed to be like a disk showing the
stand evasion and that's like the points
all kind of all over the place so if you
look at the means here the kind of true
meaning is kind of 5:5 that's the fan
paint is supposed to converge to but
it's actually sort of the cross is where
they mean where the mean of our
prediction is it actually kind of just
kind of ambles around it and kind of
bounces kind of back and forth and then
kind of eventually kind of gets there
but it's still taking huge strides
and kind of if you have an allowing or a
lower learning rate than this then it
just blows up and you get non values in
contrast with the kind of pathways
derivative or the reformation trick and
you find that it kind of nicely slowly
goes towards the right direction towards
a black dot yeah so I just interrupted
it now
okay so we're back to where we are
there's a very good paper which kind of
kind of kind of explains how to take
kind of ingredients through kind of
Monte Carlo kind of estimates it's
called gradient estimation using
stochastic computational graphs and it's
by ash women at war it out right okay so
can we train this on old data and so
when we're kind of kind of collecting
new data is collecting new data is very
expensive and so sometimes you might
want to kind of reuse our old data and
but if we look at this objective it says
that the trajectory or the kind of our
kind of states of action samples kind of
have to be in the kind of current policy
that we're in so that's why it's called
policy gradient because it's on policy
you can you can derive a kind of off
policy version but it's really nasty and
so you can use something called
important something which is usually
used for when you want to kind of reduce
the variance of an expectation so in
this case so in this case kind of pie
bar would be our kind of policy under a
new trajectory sorry would be a kind of
new policy another new new parameters
and an approximation to this gives us
this really horrible kind of objective
and the kind of really bad thing about
this is that so this term over here is
kind of exponential in your time and so
it can blow up or kind of go to zero and
also kind of using
a baseline can also help you kind of
reduce the variance of your gradients
and so you can the way you can show this
is by taking the expectation of the grad
log of your policy times B and showing
that equals to zero now you might be
wondering like why we you might want to
do this well if you take and so if you
take the if you calculate the variance
of this by taking the expectation - and
expectation s squared then you will kind
of find that the variance kind of can
decrease with a good baseline and a good
baseline is typically an average reward
and we'll come back to that later so the
kind of pros and cons of policy gradient
is that sort of one big Pro is that you
can learn stochastic policies and and
the reason why that's good is like for
example if you've got a game of
rock-paper-scissors then if you've if
you have a deterministic policy and then
like an opponent can easily exploit that
by kind of for example if you've if you
always kind of decide to do and kind of
scissors and after your opponent is
rocked and they're polling that can
exploit that and kind of always win and
we'll see kind of a good example in just
a bit and you can work with discrete and
continuous action spaces and so
generally it's hard to kind of modify
your algorithm to work with continuous
action spaces and but there's kind of no
reason why you can't do both and because
in our objective and it works fine there
kind of
gradients are unbiased and so it means
that you can kind of converge to a local
optimum and they're kind of on the cons
we've seen that the variance is kind of
very high and we can take some measures
to reduce that like using a larger batch
size or smaller learning rate it's also
not straightforward to kind of implement
a width of policy data and if you've got
an environment that's deterministic then
it learns less quicker their new
terminus T policies
okay so and one kind of a good example
of a game I found and is so you're an
environment and and each of these
squares is a state that you can be in
and obviously you want to get the the
kind of money back and you want to avoid
their skulls now if you're using a
stochastic if you're using a
deterministic policy so in this
environment and the environment is kind
of is partially observable so the state
doesn't so when the states on one of the
gray spots it doesn't know whether it's
on the left one on the right one because
it seeds a door either way but if you're
learning deterministic policy then you
have to choose one and so you'll kind of
be so if you if you're on the left then
you'll kind of be stuck and in that kind
of loop and you won't get help
but in this stochastic policy you would
it would probably you you would have
like an even probability of going left
or right so we looked at policy based
methods and now we're going to look at
value based methods and the question is
can we met the policy gradients
completely and so kind of we return to
our initial objective which is that we
want to visit and Q values and remember
the Q values are the the Q's and values
are given the state in action is the
kind of expected reward from that state
and so we want to kind of visit the
optimal ones so we always so when we're
out of state and we've been presented
with different actions we want to go to
the Q that's heist and and
so we want to yeah so we want to take
the action basically that where we're
always in kind of a little more queue
states so obviously no all actions are
you cool if we know the optimal action
value we've kind of solved the problem
and so we can land the optimal key
values directly and so we'll talk about
that in a bit so one method we can use
is something called bootstrapping and
that basically says that we can kind of
get our kind of a better estimate of the
value in our current state by knowing
the kind of value in the next state and
so the intuition is is that there are
rewards flow kind of from the future
time sets to the present time steps
another way of looking at is that the
value estimates at high time steps are
more reliable so for example if you if
you're kind of one step before terminal
state then then you've then you've got a
much lower variance because there's only
a few actions that you can take and a
few rewards you can get but if you're at
the start of your MVP
then there's lots of possibilities that
you can of kind of rewards that you can
get so a for finite number of states
kind of so development of demand the
operators to find those so be and of the
value state is the action that maximizes
your reward and plus gamma x so
this tea here is that transition
dynamics matrix but you can think of it
as an expectation after kind of next
values and it can be shown too it can be
shown that it's a contracting operator
and that basically means that if we keep
applying the bellman optimality operator
then we can kind of converge to optimal
value States and so it also applies to Q
values too unfortunately when we're
using deep learning we don't have any
kind of guarantees on the convergence
and see why that's the case is that
usually and so we're working in
continuous States so we don't kind of
construct the matrix in typical Q line
and what we want to do is we want to so
why here is there kind of is the target
is the target value so why here is
basically the maximum of the road plus
the next value step and we want to kind
of minimize bellmen error and and so
that should be there should be a beta it
should be B operator here and basically
what you can show is that when you have
both of these contractions together then
you don't get a contraction anymore and
but you can still kind of expect some
kind of good results and this problem is
known as the deadly triad and and if you
want to know more about it you can look
in a certain and batos book
okay so for deep queue networks we have
our cue function as a reward plus gamma
times the maximum the action that
maximizes that the maximum Q value in
the next state and we want to minimize
this error so I put kind of ice cubes
kind of over this target value this
target Q because we actually don't want
to change so we don't want to back
propagate gradients for our target value
and because we're using it as a
reference unfortunately we're not kind
of learning a maximum likelihood
estimation anymore and that's because
we're using that's because our kind of
target and why is no longer our kind of
max our kind of target Q value is isn't
accurate it's still an estimation and
yeah so the target Q body is biased and
told ya and at how cute and SMA Q values
are correlated so kind of just to
understand the problem instability in a
Q learning a bit more we can think of
our kind of Q values as being
parameterised so we can think of our Q
values as a net and where the net is
kind of where the shape of the net is
kind of traumatized by theta our neural
network parameters so when we have high
local Q value that's larger than our
initial estimate we update our
parameters using stochastic gradient
descent and we pulled the net higher
unfortunately when we pulled the net
higher we also pull the neighboring
points as well and we might not
necessarily want to do that
and so if we upgrade a policy in every
time step we effectively keep and kind
of increasing the net pulling up the net
in the same place so one way to kind of
mitigate this is by kind of randomizing
the kind of state's actions rewards and
that we kind of feed in to our objective
and so this is called a replay buffer so
the replay buffer basically stores your
state action reward and next date -
Falls and then when you want to update
the q-value you take a tuple from random
and that kind of ensures that you're not
picking the kind of the tuples that are
next to each other and this kind of
state star next to each other and
actions that are next to each at the
state action pairs that are next to each
other
and so you're not getting that kind of
problem we kind of discussed before it's
really easy to implement and there's no
kind of correction term and so basically
we just kind of and changed
they're kind of the expectation part so
now it's our tuples are coming from the
buffer so that's our objective and okay
so another way we can kind of mitigate
the issue is by decoupling the target
Network parameters from the estimated
queue and so there's kind of two places
where we can get the target parameters
so one is by having a totally new queue
network and sort of saying queue network
kind of trained on different samples and
so that would kind of
health could have increased stability or
we can use an usually what's usually
used is an older saved network of our
queue values and the downside to that is
that the older kind of Q values are
still somewhat correlated with the
current Q values sometimes you can use
kind of polyak so yeah so one so one way
of kind of adjusting the network
parameters is using Polyakov urging so
we're just slowly updating or Thea
parameters and so you can see an example
so this diagram here as well so after
every and K number of steps you kind of
transfer your current and theta to your
your target Q theta okay so choosing an
exploration policy for laps so when we
kind of run the algorithm we need to
make a kind of decision about kind of
what actions we take and so kind of
initially you might think that you want
to take the actions that maximized Q
value the next Q value and because then
you're more likely to kind of go into
regions with a higher reward but
sometimes what you might find is that
and if you explore kind of kind of
uncharted areas they might have kind of
much higher Q values and usually kind of
a good exploration policy can be kind of
difference between a really bad
algorithm in a really good algorithm and
so one common one is called epsilon
greedy so with a certain probability you
choose maximum Q that you choose an
action and with the maximum Q value
otherwise you
kind of choose any other action at
random okay there are some other kind of
exploration kind of heuristics one
common one is called Boltzmann
acceleration we just basically take the
action kind of proportional to the
exponential of the q function after your
different actions okay so that's a kind
of overview of deep Q learning so you
kind of save your target Network
parameters you kind of run a rollout and
you can kind of choose which what policy
you am used to run a rollout and then
use sample some tuples from your replay
buffer and then you kind of train this
loss so there's different things you can
so you can tweak the algorithm in in
different ways so you can choose to for
example before you can choose for
example to take a loop from say four to
three in a cycle if you wanted to if for
example kind of gathering data is very
expensive
okay another problem in kind of
q-learning is this kind of problem of
overestimating our Q values so usually
and one way I kind of try to minimize
this bellman error or temporal
difference error we're taking away kind
of constantly kind of minimizing this
entire bellman error but actually kind
of what you want is so ideally in like
an ideal world you kind of want so our Q
values are noisy and you want the you
want to take the bellman difference off
the kind of true Q value and of the true
kind of Q values for your target and
current state and so ideally you'd want
to kind of take the kind of expectation
of those Q values but what you're in
fact doing is you're taking an
expectation over the maxes and and that
basically means that you're kind of
overestimating your target Q value okay
so in double Q learning and they kind of
get around that and this kind of issue
of kind of D correlating the noise and
in our kind of actions we take from the
noise and the values and it's by any
kind of a subtle method and they
basically choose a different network to
select action from the from the network
to kind of evaluate values so that's our
kind of current sorry that's our current
target value and just a one thing we
change is now we kind of take the odd
max over
they're kind of over the kind of the
current q-value parameters or the new
target parameters and that basically
works to kind of be correlate this noise
issue and so in the double q-learning
paper they found that so I'm not sure
how they got their true value but what
they found was that in double Wendy kind
of applied at fixed than their value
estimates working a much marker up okay
so okay so there's a kind of a notebook
for cue line as well one second so you
might just want to take a bit of time to
kind of look into that
so it's this one here it's called double
D Q and in breakout I think I did the 3
later on for my own reference so you
might just want to take a couple of
minutes to kind of look on that
okay so
so come play the baby of some way
sniffing okay so um there's kind of a
few things I just want to kind of point
out in here and that is so it's so
you're working in environment of
breakout and now this is an example this
is an example of partially observable
MDP because given our current state so
if you so like this picture is a state
that would be kind of usually fed in to
our MVP now from that state you don't
know whether it's moving right or left
and so it's a partially observable MDP
and the way to the way usually they
forward hary games they kind of obviate
this issue is by stacking the previous
frames as well so over here you've got
four previous frames that are kind of
stuck together so here
and
the other kind of subtlety probably that
you might and I notice is that so our Q
functions a function of our state and
actions but for the network we only
input our states and we kind of empower
our only our states because we want to
get the Q function for all our possible
actions and so the output of a network
is the Q functions for and for that
particular state and all the different
actions and the reason why we do it this
way is that it's very easy to do two odd
max because then you can just select the
highest Q value and donnell subtlety
with
yet so with normal kind of dqn the
target values are kind of
straightforward to kind of implement and
the only thing you need to do 4wqn is
just get the old max or that other
network and of the kind of current
action values key values and so here's
another thing as well so we want to so
we used TF don't stop gradient and for
our target values because we don't want
to propagate freedom and actually in
this particular case and the way it's
out you don't need to use TF don't stop
gradients because when you've got the
copy the after network the gradients
can't by prop grave anyway okay so all
this connects so they're kind of lost
kind of kind of group of algorithms is
called
that we're looking at is actor critic
algorithms and so basically we've looked
at policy based methods and we've looked
at value based methods and we want to
know is there a way of kind of combining
both of them together so with with the
policy based methods we saw that we saw
that they were unbiased but the variance
was quite large and the kind of
intuition for wide variance was so large
is because when you're taking the
expected returns when you're taking the
rollouts and you can have lots of
different possible returns and so you
can have for the same policy you can
have one very high return and one very
low return and but for Q values we saw
that
we found that they were biased because
of development operator and not that
can't be applied and for deep learning
but the variance is also the variance
however is very low and the reason for
that is because you're just taking the
mean squared error between your current
Q value and the estimate of your next Q
value and your next Q value won't change
much over your algorithm as you're
training so okay so if you look at kind
of our kind of objective degree in this
we want to take and kind of in place of
Phi we have the kind of expected return
so if we take Phi as just kind of
expected return as a way of kind of
running our policy then we have a policy
gradient algorithm and we can apply a
kind of control variant or baseline to
reduce the variance however this is the
exact same thing as the Q value so the
reason why I've put the Q value over
there as well is because you can
parameterize your Q value with a neural
network and so it will be biased and but
the kind of objective is the thing and
but you'll have lower variance a kind of
a good baseline to use is your value at
your current state and so when you take
Q minus V it's called an advantage and
the kind of intuition behind that is
that you're kind of advantage is you're
so your advantage a particular state in
action is so if you take a particular
it's so a particular state your
advantage is how much better its
particular action compared to any other
action and you saw that sorry and we saw
that we can apply the kind of baseline
as long as it's kind of independent of
your actions and so your expectations
won't change
oh sorry the expectation of the
gradients and won't be different but
it'll just be lower the variance of them
will be lower and so with the advantage
they're written over there as Q minus V
and you can train using two different
neural networks if you wanted to only
use one neural network then you can just
write Q as your sir over your Q is your
Q value is your kind of the reward you
get at your tape after you take a
particular action and plus the kind of
some of your rewards if you kind of run
the policy and they expected some of the
rewards if you kind of run a policy and
and so that's just basically rewards
plus your discount factor times you're
on x value state and so and this is a
kind of typical kind of algorithm for Q
actor critic so kind of one thing to
kind of point out is that so you've got
two different neural networks and you
need to update Q and C you're updating Q
using the bellman error as well or the
temporal different Sara and and so this
objective is still biased because of
that Q but the variance is greatly
reduced
and and here's one for the the advantage
actor critic and it's basically very
similar except we've taken the we've
taken the advantage to be and so we've
just taken instead of the cue over here
we've just used so on the last line it
says theta you update the kind of theta
using advantage times gradient of love
point you just changed the cue to your
advantage and so I think yeah so there's
a a notebook for this particular
algorithm and that's the last notebook
on there so you might want to look at
that it's called yeah advantage actor
great acquit and the kung-fu gym
environment
so there's not much so you're trying to
different in your network so one for
your policy and one for your value and
but other than that there's not much
that's different from and policy
gradient
okay so kind of I've trained it and so
if you get home you can have a look at
it as well and so it kind of works
pretty well I'm going to go back to the
slides and so let's take a look at one
of the advantage estimates okay okay so
if we look at our advantage estimates
again and so we were using we were
trying to minimize the temporal
difference error and using between by
kind of minimizing the error between the
current Q value state and your next next
value state you can get a lower you can
expand your next value State as your as
a reward plus gamma times the next value
state two steps on and you can keep
doing that and eventually you basically
get the policy gradient and with a
baseline which is your value state and
so kind of you the kind of range from
here is that you have a high bias and
low variance at the top but at the
bottom you have a low vison high
variance so at the top the reason why so
at the bottom the reason why you have a
high variance is because the rewards
from the rewards from your rollout can
have a high variance so under the same
policy you can have lots of different
you can have a kind of a great range of
returns and and the reason why you've
got a low variance at the top is because
you're only kind of is only kind of the
kind of variance you get from your value
state your next value state and you're
the kind of reward at the next when you
take an action at that stain
okay so I'll just kind of skip this so
um there's okay so kind of one of the
more kind of advanced algorithms is
called DD PG and deep deterministic
policy gradient and it looks at the kind
of so if we look at back at the if we
look back at Q learning we have to take
we had to take an egg max over the Q the
Q values and however if you're working
with a continuous action space then you
can't really it's very difficult to kind
of find a way to take an egg Max and so
the intuition behind DD PG is that you
want to take so if you so you use the
deterministic policy and your
deterministic policy is kind of
dependent on your state and you just
kind of differentiate your Q values see
you just basically kind of take the
derivative of your deterministic policy
with respect to your and Peter from your
Q values and because you want to kind of
take gradient ascent and to kind of make
sure you get a policy that kind of
maximizes the Q values and
and so the loss is just basically so
you've got to loss see you got your loss
from your critic and which is just
computed with you or bellman error and
then you lost with your actor which you
can do using chain rule and so it won't
really go into this other algorithm it's
called trust I won't go too much into it
so it's called trust region policy
optimization and basically it kind of
looks at the kind of the variance the
kind of high variance issue and in usual
policy gradient and what it does is it
tries to so they're kind of intuition
behind it is if you've got a policy and
which is parametrized by theta if you
kind of change theta by a small amount
then there's a possibility you can have
a completely different wild policy
especially if it changes you can as
especially if it changes the policy at
the especially if it changes their kind
of actions towards the beginning of the
directory and so the kind of solution is
well why don't we constrain the kind of
the policy our new policy from our old
policy and with a KL divergence and I
mean it's constrained and so that it's
less than Delta and it works much much
better than old algorithms we've seen so
far including DDP G and so kind of
lastly I kind of want to talk about why
deep reinforcement learning isn't really
kind of ready to be kind of deployed at
large
it's a really hard for a number of
reasons and so classical robotic
techniques kind of in optimal control
outperform RL already
and it's - it's to date a hungry
usually kind of when you're working with
complex environments then you have to
wait a very very long time before you
see your kind of rewards starting to
pick up it also requires a reward
function and that's kind of man-made as
well and so in sometimes there's
environments where it's very difficult
to see kind of how you can kind of
allocate your rewards in the best way
and you can fall into suboptimal
behaviors and I'll show one example of
that on the next slide and it's poor at
generalization and transfer learning and
it's very sensitive to high perform to
tuning and this can make it really
frustrating because usually you don't
know so if you've built a new algorithm
then you have to wait a very very long
time before you can work out whether
your algorithm is good or not because
for for a long time you're just going to
have your kind of fix you're going to
have your kind of rewards kind of be
kind of like close to zero or kind of
like Plateau to begin with and the kind
of variants and noise issue in
reinforcement learning is kind of very
high so here's an example on the VGO
environment and so I encourage you to
kind of get it if you can so if you're a
student and then you
have it you can kind of download it for
free and it's compatible with an opening
a gym and so I think for this particular
environment they used an algorithm
called normalize advantage functions and
it kind of dropped into a kind of
suboptimal policy so and when you were
in a suboptimal policy like that it's
kind of very difficult to get out of it
because you're in a high rope you're in
a relatively high reward region so some
kind of research areas ongoing or kind
of multi-agent reinforcement learning
model-based reinforcement learning and
so multi-agent reinforcement learning is
when you've got lots of different agents
and and it could be kind of cooperating
or vying for some goal and and it's
quite challenging because and you're not
working you're not really working in MD
you're not really working and because
you're your environment is kind of
dynamic and so you can't use for example
your replay buffer you can't use the
states and actually as you used before
because you're kind of environment is
kind of being it's kind of it's turned
very kind of dynamic because of the
introduction of other agents so
model-based RL is another area where you
kind of where you're learning about your
model so for example you could be
learning the transition dynamics and
sometimes that can really kind of boost
your performance Metro RL which is about
kind of learning to reinforcement and
representation learning and kind of
effective exploration techniques
imitation learning and so an inverse RL
so kind of given a policy can you kind
of reverse engineer what the rewards in
the very man should be like transfer
learning
and okay so I just kind of like to end
this off we do a kind of a nice quote
around it's why Alex Earp and we works
in Google brain so several times now
I've seen people get lured by recent
work they tried deep reinforcement any
for the first time and without fail they
underestimate the perils difficulties
without fail the toy problem is not as
easy as it looks
and the feel destroys them a few times
until they set realistic expectations so
thanks for listening duster end of my
talk
[Applause]